talking about beef though let's talk
about actual
japanese beef and japanese steaks
because
like a5 are nothing a5 yeah
a5 is like i thought it's not that much
more expensive
it's it's so weird living in a country
where you can go to your local local
supermarket and get a5 beef
yeah you know and then this this is the
type of beef that gets like
shipped over and you pay like 50 bucks
for like
like a [ __ ] 100 grams or something
yeah and then you can just get it here
at your supermarket
as much as i don't rate steaks like a5
steaks
they they do the uh striking yeah
i had a wagyu burger yesterday and it
was [ __ ] amazing and i'm so glad that
there was bread lettuce and tomatoes and
cheese gum
don't stop this again away from i'm just
saying i just
it felt good you know i mean a burger
and a steak two different things in my
mind but okay
wagyu steak is like amazing especially
when they like fry that [ __ ] in butter
like so much
yeah it like absorbs it you bite into it
it's like
yeah i don't know though like for me
steak is just like
how often do you have a steak not often
that's why
i can't have steak often i i i like i
would understand
coming from your perspective why you
hate steak but to me steak is
like the best meal or the best meat you
can get
if it's like [ __ ] if it's like prepared
well right
[Music]
what's better than the good steak i
think pork is the best meat [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here like a pork
steak no no not a pork steak i just
think
well pork steaks are good like gammon
chops are [ __ ] amazing
right no no no it goes
okay here's how the [ __ ] tear this
goes okay it goes like a
an amazing steak at top i couldn't eat a
steak every day but like as a as like a
one-off meal
like steak is like that it's up there
yeah
then after that comes chicken because
chicken you can do so much wiggly
you can never get it i've bought a
chicken chicken i could eat fried
chicken every day
yeah and then below that is pork no no
below that is pork because i would never
like anything you cook with pork i feel
like you can do something similar with
chicken
no i feel like pork has a like it's the
in-between get like
whereas beef is really heavy yeah in
between and i feel like you can do so
much report like i love
i love sauces sausages are amazing yeah
but you can
also have beef sausages as well yeah
like like i've never had a beef sauce in
my life
it's like there's there's nothing you
can do with pork that you can't do with
either chicken or beef and have it taste
better yeah wait do you like hot dogs
no oh yeah he acts like a guy just like
hot dogs
how do you not like hot dogs i don't
know dude who's talking about this
because you don't like [ __ ] condoms
yeah that and also the people who talk
so highly about steak are like
no no hot dogs are for peasants that
doesn't known i couldn't possibly
i love a good hot dog does this have dog
in it
i do i love hot dogs man i i know
they're absolute garbage and like
probably cancerous but okay
you have to have like a beef sausage hot
dog though because you've never had a
beef sausage all right
tell me the difference between like a
hot dog a sausage like like a sausage
a sausage is okay if you're ever gonna
take a hot dog over sausage
i don't think we can be friends no
exactly exactly but you know when you're
a barbecue
and like you know yeah people are being
kind of cheap you know they want to
bring the big sausages you're like
fine i'll eat four hot dogs fine you
know yeah like like that's that's the
thing i would never
pick a hot dog over a sausage oh no no
no it's like a double cheeseburger right
yeah
yeah if it's there i'll eat it and this
and you can
okay with a sausage hot dog right like a
thick boy you can only put one of those
away yeah the hot dog i feel like you
can put like three or four away
oh yeah because it's so [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and they just taste
like
like they don't really like a sausage
are good because it's heavy the reason
the reason i don't like hot dogs
is that or the reason i wouldn't even
take it over with sausage is that it
just tastes so processed
yeah yeah that's because this is
something that's exactly like highly
processed food that my brain is like
wait do you like spam uh
uh it's okay you're gonna you're gonna
like laugh now
my mom's gonna feel so bad my mom used
to make this meal i [ __ ] loved it
dude i would always ask my mum to make
it it was literally mashed potatoes and
spam
just just mashed and i [ __ ] loved
this [ __ ] wait was like no
like flavoring on top of it no no just
mashed potato and spam
like imagine like a giant [ __ ] pan
of mashed potato right and i would just
take like a
giant plate full of this [ __ ] and i
would gobble that [ __ ] up man i would
eat that for dinner like cancer in a
plate
oh yeah because spam is spam is one of
those things where it's like if i'm
offered spam
on its own and i can see it i'm like get
that away from me yeah get that [ __ ]
away from me but when it's like in
something disguised i'm like yo this
[ __ ] collapsed what is that yeah
spam fried rice is like okay she's
pretty good i used to [ __ ] hate spam
like i was like ew get that [ __ ] away
from me give me real
is there like a spam hawaii in hawaii
they make like a spam sushi or something
oh no that's yeah yeah that's
inside the hawaii or okinawa i think
it's an okinawa dish with spam
i don't [ __ ] with that like spam is
[ __ ] though i don't [ __ ] with spam i
gotta know
i [ __ ] i i used to not [ __ ] with it but
spam is such a huge thing in the
philippines yeah so going to aki's
parents place
they like every second meal had spam in
it so i couldn't avoid this
spam is what i eat to remind me what
good meat tastes like okay
[Music]
what do the peasants eat nowadays i must
know oh oh
spamming hot dog and spam i suppose i
could give a hot dog and a spam a trial
tool you know
oh rather rather distasteful